I want to part to people
if I were you this
yeah
ah he always goes to the kidneys this
[ __ ] yeah well because shots
damn
is hope initially you put I'm scared yes
whoa
ah
[Music]
okay
[Music]
Kelly come back to me in human seven
feet
[Music]
she's
you
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
crazy
Oh
No No
[Music]
[Music]
uh-huh
maybe not deluxe okay we don't see them
yeah probably
[Music]
dear she has bad luck with boyfriends
[Music]
oh now they show up
[Music]
I looked his back now when tario he
shows up federal aid to these movies and
shows
[Music]
all loving our God
[Music]
three months later
don't come over here please to grow to
raise your family to walk your dog
change itself be cursed
[Music]
[Music]
yeah at this point you guys hoppers dead
worse who's 11 gonna be staying with
what she was given what's happened in my
life I can only relate to a few people
[Music]
[Music]
I understand what's happened and I like
presents - yeah cool yeah I like I like
presents - you talked about your
feelings your heart oh oh yeah that man
was so long so no it's just he's moving
stuff and when they say exactly she
heard him
[Music]
sighs room
[Music]
doesn't know how to process this move
with them it's like 10 we never see
Mike's families
jeez the truth is for so long I forgot
what those even were when that they left
some air goes out in the woods you came
into my life for the first time I
started to feel things again I start
like me I guess I've been distant from
you back here you pulling away from me I
miss playing war games every night
watching westerns together before beat
us off and I know you're getting off if
I'm being really honest
that's what scares me I don't want
things to change
[Music]
and so I think maybe that's why I came
in here to try to maybe stop that sheet
but I know that's naive
this is just not how life works
let's move always moving whether you
like it or not sometimes it's painful
sometimes it said
and sometimes we'll surprise it hey
don't let me stop when I'm with her
the hurt is good he needs your power of
that chief
nice if you don't mind the three pitches
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you crying [ __ ] feel like we should
break up
let's do doc cam not the American not
the America
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
this said not the American gonna be ha
bird it's got a kitty hopper when
Matthew Modine
I know it
in the last season
everybody aims he's like he's still out
there he's still alive and they're like
no he's dead he's like no he's still
alive no it's [ __ ] Harper John who's
blue Matt who's Matthew Rudy yeah the
white-haired guy papa
from the first season the evil scientist
who always shows up oh yeah and then in
season two they're like he's still alive
and they're like no no we killed him
he's like no no no no it could be home
you thought the Russians were like
trying to do the right thing forget
let's not forget how terrible your
theories I'm gonna repeat the plot
that's already happened up to solidify
all right let's review the show hmm I
cried a bit there wasn't a camera I'd be
bawling my eyes out ugly face the whole
time it felt it felt my face wanting to
do that but it's one of those things we
were like if my face is doing that but
not I'm wrong you know gushing tears I'm
just gonna look stupid I look stupid
either way but that's when I'm not a
season 3 guys look stupid while while
being aware that people might think so
nobody wants to look stupid obliviously
exactly yeah so that's why this is it
this is what do you guys subscribe for
really Bunga JB didn't come back I think
they're gonna make it to I think see is
enforcement it's take place 20 years
later where they're all adults now and
they're gonna come back to hawk yeah if
so much on it now in all seriousness I
thought this was a great season finale
I thought they nailed it for for the
most part actually yeah Jake Busey never
came back well that's hype about him
being in season 3 of stranger things and
he didn't really even do much and this
season actually he's a one-dimensional
douche and he's a monster for an episode
but it is one of those shows that even
if you got a one-dimensional little tiny
role you're gonna be like yeah I'll do
it I'll do it I'd love to be a part of
your family but
yeah I'm gonna kill whatever the hell
you want me to do I'll do it yeah it's
one of those shows where you would say
yes to so Livia you want to talk about
uh Billy's death did you cry and
juggling cry I do ugly fries I mean I
feel like that was really well for a
shadow too I feel like we all sort of
made remember half the things we talked
about after filming but I feel like one
of us well I mean I think we all sort of
saw that going into his psyche was
somehow wouldn't come into play with
defeating the big daddy at the end of it
all which I thought worked really well
that was the most I've ever felt for
Billy yeah always been like that's kind
of a bummer Ken he's a dick though even
when he isn't he's not [ __ ] because
that's my something you still a day but
you know I did this show really did a
great job there was a crazy visual
palette of really making you understand
why he is the way he is it's a
heartbreaker of an ending because the
guy is obviously just been in pain for
so long yeah and now he's like
physically suffering through this whole
season and it's cool that he did get to
have a moment of redemption surely have
a great sacrifice which in by the way
that was that was brutal
it was brutal the way he died about that
whole sequence with the mind flare in
the center of the star court mom and
although your wire works yes that was
some of those beautiful television I've
ever seen it's a scary moment it's like
really really intense but I can't help
it go I also look so beautiful
okay there look at how they're doing
this this is great especially as we have
good at jumping back and forth between
beautiful gripping spectacle yeah and
then jumping back right into a little
character beads and stuff like that and
I thought that you know for season
three's finale 1 & 2 both kind of end
with L closing something you know very
dramatically and so to make the choice
that her powers aren't the cure-all for
everything seemed like an appropriate
place to go at the end of season 3 what
happened with their powers exactly
though this I really explained I mean
they don't always explain everything at
the end of every season I get that
yeah I feel like the thing like zapped
her powers I feel like maybe we just
miss but she used her powers too she's
made a comment of oh I just need to
recharge yes I don't even think she
knows she doesn't know what's wrong and
I yeah I just kind of took that as
something to do with having the mind
flayer like physically inside of her
body did something weird yeah yeah at
least for me that that's one of those
things where I'm like you know I'll
allow that much mystery cuz none of us
truly know how on the upside down yeah
yeah this is so rewarding also has it
all come back together by having credit
season 2 for doing that really well for
when they all finally come together in
the penultimate episode when this when
they come together the beginning of this
episode which is just so cool to see
them all unite and I think it's great
that Murray got a lot more to do this
time around and really get a chance to
shine and his conspiracy like the thing
that's always played for a joke comes in
super handy yes but nothing with the
Russian girl and like all that you know
then they come back around and find that
he's like fluent
Suzy Suzy Suzy gonna join the catch you
better join the cast I thought that have
phoebe cates come in as Susie's mom I
like I I legit thought they kept being
like she's hotter than Phoebe Cates and
I'm like I thought they were gonna pull
some kind of a moment there I mean they
did a little bit with the cut out of her
but uh but yeah I was like that was a
really nice bookend yes you know for the
episode and also yeah with the number I
thought that was a really nice character
detail of like Marie just got the number
wrong yeah you know because of their you
know Captain America conversation about
going on that date that's what it hit me
like one of them's gonna die like I just
know it water them gonna die right it's
all too good
we did not see him like fat evaporates I
don't think he's dead I mean in season
one that they did the same thing with
eleven except that looked more like a
finite death yeah we didn't see what
happened with hopper and I feel like if
they did want to be like no he's
actually dead they would have with us we
would have seen it there was still
something that felt a little bit
unresolved like granted when it was
getting to the moment where 11 was
reading the letter and then you would
cut to hopper and he you see him writing
the letter I was really getting me in
the fields because despite the fact that
I don't I'm not under the belief that
yeah
David Harper's not coming back for
season 4 you know I'm not under that
belief the moments of the characters and
especially Millie Bobby Brown's acting
of reacting to the letter that really
got me really it's like people can argue
that it's always been her show but I
feel like this season more than the
others especially because she's not
quiet at all she's interacting with a
lot of people in this whole season she
gets some of the biggest you know
emotional moments throughout I feel like
this is really her season this is her
coming out of her shell a lot yeah for
sure and again it's always that thrust
of the character growth that helps to
entire everything and make it also
compelling but there were also just like
so many fists whooping like fun moments
and they're really good at making you
forget about people like throughout this
episode I would forget about a plot
thread that's like when Steve shows back
up yet the car a little different things
like that they are great at turning up
the heat and the intensity to where
you're not thinking about everybody we
had the immediate situation really is
just like one immediate situation yes
yeah to watch them all now have to work
together via radio after being separated
on it's like it's cool because you get
them all back together for a minute but
then they all have to work together
remotely and that's fun to watch too
because he also goes just further down
the rabbit hole of that childlike you
know like they're always on the
walkie-talkie he's like doing crazy
stuff and now they have like a legit
operation run with his radio tour and
everything over all season thoughts
though I kind of felt a little bit of a
lackluster development with will to be
honest yeah I thought they had a great
Buy cool setup with
character of him feeling I mean it ends
in a way that leads to what they were
kind of talking about early on in this
season of we're not always gonna be
together
in fact now they're really not who's
gonna be together here they're living
apart I like the commitment to Joyce
actually leaving Hawkins that just makes
sense on a character level that makes
the most sense that she would make the
decision that they're gonna have they're
gonna leave Hawkins especially after all
this drama yeah they're gonna leave Mike
do not feel like a lead at all and not
that he's supposed to feel like a lead
he did feel more like a supporting
character here although I did really
like the a lot of times you know when
shows when they get together and then
they're not together but you want them
to get back together I can get kind of
annoyed with that but I thought this
season handled it really well to the
point where when 11 does say to Mike
that she loves him too I found that to
be a very rewarding moment and it felt
well-earned and Mike still did have
growth in his character but he did feel
more like a supporting character this
season time around Jonathan got the most
to do this episode might felt like a
support to L and then yeah Jonathan's a
support to Nancy yes it felt like hopper
and Joyce's show and 11:00 show this
specific it's like they had the multiple
storylines going on where 11 is that's
her storyline where Dustin and Steve are
that's their storyline hopper and Joyce
are that's her storyline and they felt
like they were the main leads and it was
cool that it had off some reins to
Dustin for this episode too because in
the last season Dustin kind of did some
stuff that wasn't a good choice on his
end made some mistakes saying that over
really backfired and then here he really
gets to shine a lot and Steve is just
like to think about where Steve is comes
the season one it's insane you know
Billy does not have that level of art
obviously but for Steve to go from like
ultimate douche bag to probably like the
most likeable character and a fan
favorite too many I think is incredible
truly learning yeah about life and they
they they even worked in gate mez
Medora Matarazzo x' pipes he's like he's
been on Broadway like he's like a legit
singer I have a photo ID they put that
in there cuz half the cast or like
embark dancer music and yeah he's done
Broadway rolled
and stuff that was really key that they
threw that in that's really adore yeah
and Erica - she was really nice like
welcome I thought there were some nice
new characters this season nobody I
thought was flat like sometimes new
characters can be hit erica was in
season two wasn't she briefly but not as
like she wasn't a Karen Samba now she
was yeah yeah like her and Alexi Cary
Elwes like Cary Elwes didn't have like a
lot of nuance to play but I mean he
showed up and had a good time and I had
fun watching him yeah and it was nice to
even see Paul Reiser come back for a
scene yeah keep the universe feeling big
yeah like credit maybe they have to come
back to Hawkins for some reason or they
going to Russia I find it interesting
for season four if they went out of
Hawkins or at least partially part of me
was thinking well maybe there's every
season that will take place over the
holidays when they can all get together
and just only weird [ __ ] happens when
they get together on things yes but yet
I have it actually leave and to kind of
spread to the world now I think would be
appropriate cuz like three times and
Hawkins I think is me well it made sense
and and I like the way other than it's
mid credit stinger this could have been
the way to be like you know if we don't
want to come back we don't have to come
back yeah never clicks continues
canceling everything yeah that made
credit scenes and one of the leaves if
like oh what's gonna happen in season
four but you know the fact that they
tell us that not only outside of Hawkins
but outside of America there's a way to
get into the upside down especially
after they said they'd failed in Russia
before so yeah where did this difficult
so what are you guys doing new intrigue
yeah there's new places to go to
oh so hop it gotta kill Arnold which we
all saw coming it's still very rewarding
though it's one of those things where
you're like we know it's gonna happen
it's gonna be awesome yeah you got to
rewarding Lee kill him twice even though
the first time like he leaves before he
gets back up so in that moment
technically hopper does kind of win
there and hopper wouldn't have been able
to walk past all that electricity going
off right no yeah yeah cuz I mean if
that's the stuff that explodes out and
vaporizes everybody anyway you know like
I'm sure he would be he's got to be the
American he's gotta be firm an audience
perspective they wouldn't have his teas
I feel like they would want to let us
know like no don't worry there's a
chance they're just you know this is
probably I'm thinking
the other characters who haven't died
but who have vanished who are American
would certainly have found her body uh
reanimate bar bring her back again yeah
season for the big bad is I think that's
a good teaser for hot but I also kind of
hope in the back of my mind that it's
maybe something like very unexpected but
also under our noses because I don't
know there's a lot of ways hop could
come back mm-hmm via reticle II well
where would you rank this season uh I
mean it just ended thus far to me the
seasons have kind of improved as they've
gone I thought one was alright I like to
a lot and I had a great time watching
this this is my favorite season so far
so I would put three one two yeah I
probably say three one two as well I'm
pretty surprised about how many people
have come out and said that this is
probably their favorite season so far
yeah there's just a few picks I have
like I do wish we got more with Billy's
Ark really I wish we got more Billy max
moments versus that was one of mine
endings - is that in this three month
later jump we didn't see any of how this
affected max last season he was such an
ass to even max yeah like and she cares
so deeply for him like out of nowhere I
would get that but like they kind of
hated each other last scene yeah you
know and so this deep caring really kind
of comes out of nowhere I get the most
because they are related but I do wish
we got more of that behind the scenes
look between them like maybe little
scenes in even in his memories of him
like caring for her and that's why
they're so deeply connected behind the
scenes as they have those little moments
but we didn't get that sauce cracked
maybe even a tad more of his internal
struggle because one of the most
interesting things about a lot of his
action moments is the fact that in his
performance you know you see the anguish
and the struggle and the fact that yeah
Billy is still there even though his
body's doing all these terrible things
it was nice to have those nuggets but I
thought they could have made more
especially if they're gonna kill him off
and they want them to have a huge impact
well they're gonna he's like the focus
central bad guy in the first half of the
season and then honestly when he showed
up in the car at the end I'm like oh
yeah Billy yeah
I was thinking about like all the other
bad guys like Arnold Schwarzenegger mind
flayer Russians
oh yeah the Billy yeah Frey Connor not
that I felt that this was rushed it's
that weird feeling of I thought actually
eight episodes that made this really
tight season it doesn't feel like it was
rushed at the same time I do feel a
little bit left empty on certain things
that didn't fully yeah there's certainly
it it could have been a little more
robust it could have been a little more
flesh or even Joyce with Bob they set up
like she's still grieving over it and
yeah we didn't really really see you
know she does have a conversation
there's nothing that happens to show
that she's over it you know other than
like I'll go on a date with you but
still you know I'm like this she's the
placing like two days really like there
is no she really doesn't go to check on
Jonathan she goes check on will
Jonathan's not really connected with way
Lauren Joyce you know that's not really
connected to the show yeah completely
forgotten over the course of this season
yeah is the fact that Nancy and Mike are
siblings I complete that Mike is very
part of that I was telling her I was
telling her that in the car yesterday
yeah I forgot what scene happen but then
I was like driving with you I actually
forgot that they were siblings yeah
when Nancy and Karen were having the
conversation I remember having a thought
of going
how does she tie into this show you're
like they're like Nancy and all them was
just because she was dating Steve or
something and I yeah she's the sister
like it wasn't it wasn't so they're
looking for a will like worse will and
then Jonathan and Nance here together
like oh yeah they're related I totally
forgot about that I think some of the
dynamics of elements of the in Samba
lore as a thing as one and to really
hone in on this and then three hones in
on other parts because probably the
biggest takeaway with season one beyond
11 was the kids you know Mike will Lucas
Dustin like the kids yeah heart and then
that's not really the the centerpiece of
this season you know whereas like season
one that was the huge thing those
[ __ ] kids are
and then here they do feel more like
supporting players or they have their
own separate things going on like no
others four of them over here then
there's you can't just do a season with
all five of them again yeah one and now
the world is expanded to such a point I
feel like in the first season you
naturally get that time because you're
just discovering it through them and now
we've got so much - yes it is different
now it has grown and and I do appreciate
the ways it is maturing you know as a
show that's growing I like that they
manned some decisions about characters
moving on from things or us literally
leaving certain characters behind your
things like that well it's because as
humans get older you do get girlfriends
and you move on from certain friends and
you stop hanging out with them as much
as you would and people that you're a
different race that's true
so I even wonder it's like maybe next
season barely getting Jonathan and Nancy
because really what role will they play
they really don't tie into the family
bond as much yeah you know so it's like
we don't really need their characters
Nancy's still working at the newspaper
do the Nancy write that article oh
they're dead now right yeah well I kind
of got the impression that most of those
people are from here some of them off
camera work yeah that was what the main
two did so would it be surprised that
they were like oh the pretty much the
whole boardroom there yeah I mean
there's no real wraparound of that
either would Nancy I felt I tend to have
issues with time jumps in season finales
while I thought well what they presented
us was very effective
there are things in hindsight after
talking for 15 minutes
that I'm like wait a minute there's
something I did not get a wrap-up on
that I felt that for this chapter or you
know there's this book or whatever you
want to call it of season 3 I thought
there would be a better wrap around
especially because you set up that whole
thing with Nancy working with the paper
was like what's going on with the post
because I have something with an article
at the / Nancy's like oh she's doing it
you know
it seemed like they did as much tying up
will and his family are leaving town and
that's kind of the big note you leave
off on as you know all we're breaking up
the gang but yeah you don't really get a
here's the cap off to every individual
story even when they mentioned that star
court was buying up all these other
properties like really what happened
with that there's a loose end still
maybe that's the point I don't know
yeah some stuff I guess there are things
I've like tune in for season four but
you know there are things I guess we're
left to ponder so that we can uncover it
season four the time will pass and we
all get a few days yeah the spots to
sink in and know I have these kids grow
they'll they'll be forty five crazy
differs maybe buffer sex you know
because they're sixteen I do wish will
if we do get that's the next forum like
Nephilim says I haven't canceling this
is their one and we'll needs storyline
we need to know more about who will is
and the boys like we got a lot about L
so I would like to know more about who a
lot of the other characters uh season
four is gonna be the Lucas season it
might as well be at this point right
listen right step maybe Lucas and Erica
finally getting along or something like
that it could be a good way to develop
the show or max yeah I mean max was
mainly a support to enhance eleven
storyline that's I mean it's like they
they have these likes well I feel like
what they do really well they never lose
sight of who their characters are but
they sort of treat their players per
season as like chess pieces and which
way they want them to help maneuver the
specific story they're telling for this
season so I do feel like for season four
probably get a little more Lucas focus
Lucas focus it's a new energy just got
him on the side of their wrist rocket I
mean II didn't get a couple of cool
shining moments in this you know with
the slingshot and the firework dynamite
effect it was all Lucas there and I
wouldn't be surprised if Jonathan just
didn't come back for season I like this
show dude it's you may care about
this one maybe even Nancy if they were
just like oh no they went off to college
and they're in some different state I
wouldn't be surprised if they just like
wrote it that way I mean
I'm Dylan Nancy gourami I was kind of
surprised by how good of a shot she was
huh she's really good with the Cobb
that's that's what bothers me I'm like
where did she ever learn to shoot
yeah it really cheerleader personality
your dad doesn't seem like the kind of
guy who would take you shooting you know
things like moving around yeah I mean
but even with Billy at the car yeah he's
like so fun like have you ever tried
fired a gun it is not easy till I put a
shot she couldn't hit him in the head
she just she got the wind chill right
where he was that's a really hard man
that's very very guys don't have you
ever fired a gun
Oh target shooting sometime it's like
yeah why are none of my boats hitting
the target about a nun being physics
yeah I did think this was a really
tightly constructed season and I thought
the things that it mainly cared to focus
on I thought excelled so well that the
thing is that I'm overall questionable
about or feel a little bit not as
fulfilled on are things that I have to
think about they're not really the
things that the show ends and I'm like
what the hell you know I have to go oh
wait yeah but actually thinking about
this I found this a little
unsatisfactory because especially will
you know like will is probably the
biggest upset for me because he had the
whole setup with them in the beginning
it seemed like they were hinting that
he's possibly gay which I think would be
cool to explore this this was it came
across to me as but most of his scenes
are yeah the thing you already got all
the guys are really aware of yeah it's
here you know why we're all quiet oh
yeah yeah you know that's just an extra
confirmation who by the chills on the
back of my neck no
to know when it's right what he did this
season is like yeah okay you guys are in
oh yeah I know to you because I have
yeah yeah could be a thing I mean you
know passage of time and all but I did
think connected how could why can you
still feel that well I mean that was the
thing I took his yeah just like he's had
these experiences he's been in the
upside down for so long he's had the
creature physically inside him I'm sure
there's residual left over from that in
some you know he doesn't have the hive
mind but he can sit but uh the thing
with this season for certain characters
anyway I thought an especially will was
the first half of the season it felt
like there was a character story
happening him having a rift with his
friends that whole thing working goes
and destroys Castle buyers and stuff in
a moment of anguish and then once that
other scene comes up where Luke is like
no no is a good campaign he's like I'm
over it now the plots kicked in and it
feels like the plot away it's like
whatever was developing there I just
don't think there was for this plot time
and space to have a story of that
variety so I hope yeah that in the
future because they had they had less of
a dramatic setup with Dustin and somehow
that felt really rewarding at the end
even though it was like a couple of
lines like actually I really like that
that's great they're all together you
know again just I mean without all these
lights and maybe and they're in the
nighttime the best way to absorb it all
right guys well I'm grateful if you guys
have stuck with us since the beginning
of this season been a great journey
stick around we've got plenty more to
upload I'm sure Comic Con is coming up
yeah we got stuff to upload and who
knows what the next show will be Game of
Thrones and seas stranger things we need
another event show no reason but we also
have other shows on patreon see how I
did that subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell I'm not
looking at the camera when I say things
I find that I like to be rude that way
is that real people think you know like
I don't really give a [ __ ] for you to
subscribe by not really making eye
contact with you I'm really looking for
the next person to shout out here last
episode I've completely forgot that
doing page from the day shoutouts the
patience to watch stranger things and I
completely forgot to shout someone out
so here it is last one
totally jumbled TJ teach my man how old
is your daughter now is she older than
one since I saw you two months ago how's
everything going you know loose had
plenty of things about TJ John and I you
met TJ yes what did you think about TJ
tell it to the camera to TJ by looking
in the camera and talking to a bunch of
people but give the message to TJ man
you're kind of stretching it a little
bit enough something live a man that
that man who came to your apartment he
seemed nice elegant very nice and you
seemed very friendly and that's also a
way to be nice affable he's capable
mm-hmm already is Darius gregarious uh
you had a great laugh you have a child
that's nice it's a quality that's a
great quality and amazing thanks for
repopulating the earth yeah doing your
part did it all by herself
see that's touching himself he he
managed to do it can you imagine though
if that's only the tower that would be
up that would be the world would have
died a long time would be no research
every sperm was truly sacred and they
didn't have to fight to the death
[Laughter]